the Joe Rogan experience dude those who
throw stones always live in a glass
house they always do it that's the first
person to throw something is the first
person that's like what's really going
on with you hey by the way by the way by
the way by the way by the way you see
Louis gank fest yeah what a response
interesting
our boy Tim Dylan tweeted about it and
people went after him
he tweeted best moment of the of my year
or something like that you know what
someone said to me people lost it they
said I [ __ ] loved him Dylan someone
said that you know hey [ __ ] you joe
rogan he sexually assaulted women like
man that's i understand that people are
upset about what he did but he did not
sexually assault women and to say that
the one the one err the one group of
people that it really [ __ ] his people
have been actually sexually assaulted
yes well sure it's not what he does not
good but when a guy says can i jerk off
in front of you
and you say yes and he does it it is a
big big demonstrating that and sexual
assault and contrary to popular opinion
and how many people really know the
story and again not saying that what he
did was good we did was definitely not
good when people said no he didn't do it
it's not like he made people do it and
say yes he asked questions and a lot of
people don't know this I'm not does not
and I saw an article in one of these
papers it was saying that he's changing
his story like he's not changing his
story but he said was their stories were
true but in their stories he I don't
think he wanted to defend every single
aspect of it but as far as I know he
didn't
no one said no when they did it anyway
that's what I've that's all I've ever
heard and Sarah Silverman talked about
how he would ask her and she would say
yes and he would do and sometimes she
would say say no right sometimes I would
see you jerk off stop right but he's a
freak okay he's a weirdo this is genius
comic and I don't think he's as bad as
people want to believe he is I think he
made mistakes like a human and I don't
you know I don't think it was good and
again I don't think he's happy about it
at all and by everything that's a
giant understatement but when does it
end
like why is he allowed to perform when
is he allowed to perform for people who
forgive him when when is he allowed to
perform I don't know is the conversation
comes to a point where it's not like
you're endorsing terrible behavior but
you are saying at a certain point in
time you got to give someone a way out
because if you don't then they start to
recognize what you are right okay and
you're kind of a tyrant and you're kind
of saying you don't believe in
forgiveness you don't believe in
improvement you don't believe in anybody
ever getting past a bad deed that they
did and I think I guess a human who's a
kind she tried to be a kind person try
to be a fair person you know you got a
you got to let people grow and move past
mistakes I don't know when it is I don't
know what someone has to say in order to
get you to forgive it but the fact that
people do well on it and unless it's
someone unless you and him have a
personal thing and you want to talk to
him about it he should sir and I don't
know if he has I don't know if he's done
any of that stuff but I think as a
culture we are way too quick not just to
condemn but to attack and to continue to
attack relentlessly and to never want
someone to get up and that's not the
sign of a compassionate person and maybe
it's partly to blame for people who
don't express themselves and don't give
you a full version of who they are and
you let people contemplate who you are I
think anyone in the public eye has been
guilty of that to some extent but this
is a significant issue and I think that
people immediately start taking sides
and they start going girl versus boy
right male versus female and I think
there's real danger and not splitting up
like that - I think that we can't get to
this place where women feel like they
can't trust men and men feel like they
can't trust women just universally and
then you find rare exceptions like a red
[ __ ] like that before
like I've read some lady wrote it was so
it's kind of sad she wrote like any
straight white male is trashed and less
proven otherwise it's like look I know
it must be hard okay dude I know it must
be hard
same thing to cast such a big net not
just even all Filipinos have a bad leg
but you're brought you're broadcasting
into your system a thousand followers
right putting that on your Twitter page
it's silly the crazy way you can't
encompass an entire group of humans ever
ever ever ever does it make sense
doesn't make sense so what the [ __ ]
wait like look I don't get where they're
coming from should I feel like they're
gaining ground sure so a guy like louis
c.k comes back and they're thinking that
connected him with Harvey Weinstein and
Bill Cosby no I don't think it's the
same thing and I don't again I don't
think what he did was good look I have
all dog we've turned off in front of him
when I really don't want it sure sure
it's it's not good I'm sorry about that
last summer I didn't mean no but [ __ ]
come on man I just I just think that
like we have classes of crimes you don't
know you're not gonna do it in this in
this world you said they're all the same
and then I heard someone I was seeing
someone saying what he did was
definitely a crime I was like come on
you might be upset that he did it but
it's not a crime it's wrong though it's
unfortunate the real problem the real
issue is that he was in a position where
these girls were admiring him right
that's the real and I think he
recognized that I don't think he's
explained it to some people's what they
desire you know some people's
requirements and I appreciate that and I
understand that I really just think what
a lot of us are missing is just a lack
of communication and compassion and
understanding yeah I think we're missing
a lot of that totally and we're real you
know we got to think of people like
anytime someone I mean I don't talk
about people that are serial killer so
I'm just talking about people who make
mistakes
you got a treat there we're all human
beings yeah people make mistake we [ __ ]
up doesn't mean you're a cancelled
person yeah that we got to stop with
that I really I really think that right
cuz I just think that it's not helping
anybody
and it's getting people's jollies off
cuz I watched someone crashed down yeah
people love to watch someone [ __ ]
burn I was also thinking that also when
the kind of this kind of stuff happens
people don't want to ever reconsider
their opinion on person
[Applause]